there's a trans-racial influencer named
ollie london this is the british chick
that said that she's korean
yes
and she's planning to get that guy
[Laughter]
he's
okay so this ollie london is planning to
get penis reduction surgery in order to
look more korean
she's trolling right like this chick is
just trolling yeah that's crazy she's
their takashi
there and she's one of these people that
understands
all publicity
she looks she looks strange she looks
korean he's he now oh he's he so be
respectful
are you sure uh according to newsweek he
has revealed that he's looking into
undergoing penis reduction certainly why
then why did he yo that's such a flex
wait i'm cute i'm looking into that too
you know i'm looking into yo i'm looking
yo what a fire headline
oh my god where's my publicist put that
[ __ ] out of everything
right there hey do something
schultz is looking into
penis reduction surgery how much you
taking off uh honestly to be honest
please
i think i gotta take away half minimum
really yeah how big is it
at least
i gotta take away at least six to eight
inches
yeah i gotta take at least six to eight
inches if my girl's gonna get pregnant
yeah yeah i'm sticking just you know i'm
stick
the thing yeah yeah the thing no for
real because that is a fire headlight
gives penis it's just so big that it's
causing pain for my girl
and not you not me that [ __ ] don't hurt
me dog
you don't step on it ever nah never step
on it i got a doctor i got a grower am i
calling him right now please call call a
penis reduction doctor but isn't that a
fire headline yeah yeah but it's to
appear more korean which is the funniest
part of it
it's a part of his transformation is
what it says so he's not doing it
because his dick is huge he's doing it
because his dick is too big to be korean
um
what are we doing right now yeah
dr alter's office excuse me um we were
just looking up do you guys i know you
do uh
penis reconstruction surgery and
different things is there a reduction
surgery that you offer
um can i place you on hold sure yo
dub had them on speed dial son wait who
did you just call big dick dub bruh who
did you just call you've been looking
into this the doctor that does the thing
he said to do the thing okay when they
come back we can we don't have to listen
to a thing but we'll get to that where
were we just talking i'm saying she's
not she's not doing it because her dick
is huge just he's doing it because dick
is too big to be korean in his mind yeah
i understand why she's why she's doing
it what i'm saying is like if you
weren't transracial oh yeah trying to be
asian and then just be it in the most
offensive way yeah yeah
you this person is committed to asian
hate yeah
like
wait what was this person born as
original white dude why dude come on
white british dude and now it's bts but
now it's she
or still i don't [ __ ] know what this
thing is it says it was she first it
says
woman first obviously it's a white woman
who else would do this
oh so it was a white woman first yeah
you just said it was white dude first i
think he was born a dude
and i think transitioned into a girl
and now he's transitioned back into a
male korean
really
is that accurate i mean i don't know i
think it has to be born a dude we're in
a post-truth society okay and it's i
don't know if it's possible to know what
gender this person started as but we
know it's a he now it's a he now no it
was always born with the dick because
it's getting it reduced
yeah i i'm i thought
it was born a female thank god
you put on that chop and they got the
wrong trick yeah yeah possibly could
have got the wrong dick can you do a
brazilian dick lift
can you take fat from your body and then
stuff it into your dick oh you make a
fatter dick yeah yeah do you have fat or
is it just cartilage one day
oh yeah i don't think it's just
cartilage blood it's just blood and
muscle
what muscle
yeah it just engorges with blood
there's cartilage isn't it cartilage no
there can be cartilage what about when
you break your dick
oh what is that that's the soft spongy
something right yes spongy tissue it's
tissues
i don't know if it's muscle
well something happens where you break
your dick like sometimes there are guys
who have broken their dick and then when
they break them apart
you strain the muscle you sprain
no you don't sprain them you strain or
tear that's why i thought it was
cartilage
isn't the stuff in between your knee
bones the same as dick
no i don't think so you think that's
dick that's also your ears and it's like
your acl is dick
yeah
like if you tear your acl you could just
put part of your dick in there
you could right you take it
100
that's what obj did dude oh [ __ ] yeah
you take a little piece of his dick like
you know there's some you know like if
you're a burn victim they take the back
of your thigh and they put your
yeah you can get a dick graph if you
tear your acl or your meniscus okay yeah
most people walking around with dick
meniscus dude yeah
yeah what is dick made out of say what
it says spongy tissue that's all it says
that's it dick is made out of dick bro
but they're just made out of different
balls that's actually a good question
yeah it's come out
i have mostly come in my balls and veins
as [ __ ] not on the inside
my left ball is so [ __ ] veiny dude my
girl we're talking about like when we
want to start having kids and i don't
have the heart to break it to her like
these things don't [ __ ] work
i got so much varicosity i got to get
that [ __ ] scooped and thrown up
[Laughter]
you know what i mean i went to the
doctor once because your balls extend
down when you're too hot and they go up
when you're too cold right because i
think the the you have to maintain the
right temperature for our sperm or sperm
dies but my balls are just caught in a
web of varicose veins
so do they even descend yeah they
descend they come back up there's just
so much my veins look like an old
woman's feet
it's just varicosity everywhere oh
that's it absolutely
fully blue fully blue at all always blue
balls 100 absolutely dr alter offers a
solution for all that yeah i know you
could just get that [ __ ] scooped and
pulled back i remember going to a doctor
to ask about this yeah and then i was
like what's the issue here and then uh
he goes we could just get it pulled up
if it's uncomfortable for you but if not
don't worry about it
i was like was there anything wrong
health-wise he goes it's possible it
could you know like reduce sperm count
because the temperature
of your balls might be hotter because
you have the veins down there and i'm
like she's saying it might be like
harder for me to get a girl pregnant and
they're like yeah and this is when i'm
single and you're out here and
[Laughter]
that's why i always got to sit with like
one leg up like this is because
literally the veins will create so much
uh blood flow down there that i have to
reduce the blood parasite is it possible
to appear that's a parasite it's some
type of tape
it could be a gay tapeworm that's just
sucks
it's not gay but it's eating up all your
[ __ ] i have female come remember oh
yeah unlike you yeah
yeah mike is mad dude i was actually
thinking about this you know what super
gay what is that transfusion say good
blood transfusion why because if you get
your blood put in another guy yeah and
then he's getting boners all the time
with your blood that's just super good
oh cause his blood
your blood is into his death he's making
his dick all hard if that's what makes
sticks hard but that'll make you gay
that makes the recipient gay yeah my
dick doesn't get hard from blood it gets
hard from [ __ ] and fat tits
nobody's blood that's literally making a
heart no it's a dick bro no it's not
it's a tissue of blood it's a dick dude
it's acl yeah
my dick just gets hard and it's dick in
there bro it's not blood it's spongy
tissue so yeah it's spongy tissue i have
blood in my arm and i could squeeze it
bro
blood doesn't make you if your blood
made your body hard you just walk around
like this all day
right like a mummy right why is it just
when blood goes into your dick it's
super hard it can break is it spongy
again it's spongy tissue no it's not
spongy sometimes it is if i'm not that
into it it's always good
but for the most part but for the most
part it's super hard blood is what makes
your dick hard it's cartilage bro it's
not it's acl it's sponge it's spongy
tissue it's not spongy tissue full of
blood
you're saying once the blood hits the
tissue it creates some sort of like a
brighter shampoo
have you ever seen the dried out my dick
is a black panther dude
my dick is black panthers insult my dick
that's you'll get
have you ever seen an old sponge under a
sink yeah that's your flaccid dick no
what happens when you fill it with water
it gets super hard and it comes all over
girls
yeah it does
look it's spongy tissue that literally
fills up and then you have muscles
located at the bottom at the base okay
and that's what makes it no the muscles
have to be throughout that's what that
spasm is what what's up when you come
it's just a spasm and it's boom what
sound did you make for that
that's the comb coming out
yeah it comes coming out it's the sound
of the police
[Laughter]
is that what you sound like that's what
i do what do you sound like when you
come
no
yeah that's my noise stop it that's yeah
what do you sound like al
i've been coming all episode
i think that it's not just blood i think
blood does something to that sponge
material you're talking about spongy
tissue it's like
you're trying to call yourself
you know what the [ __ ] the answer is
he's reading it no i'm telling you what
the answer is
you said it was blood it's blood and
some other stuff spongy tissue no it's
pterodactyl what was the [ __ ] that miles
was trying to say earlier
spina bifida it's spina bifida i'm just
saying people say it's blood that makes
your dick hard no it's not blood doesn't
make anything hard
or else we would walk around hard no
blood makes your muscles hard no it
doesn't yeah it does no it doesn't work
it out makes your muscles flex it yeah
but when you see flex what's the second
thing
what is it
[ __ ] flexing is the muscle yeah and
what's going in the muscle to make it
flex no it's just making the muscles
shorter bro you're a hydraulics makes
muscle shorter
you got him on that yeah it just makes
them shorter dude
you're squeezing it together it gets
bigger
you think it's blood going in there what
happens when you get a pump at the gym
what are you getting pumped with
you squeeze your muscles
you're squeezing them you're going like
this
you're a politician right now you're not
you're squeezing your muscles how do you
work out you go like this right now he's
putting right he's putting it you don't
you don't work out like that
you don't stretch it out at all i'm just
saying when you work out think about
what you do yeah okay you think it's
blood that gets filled there you have
the same amount of blood in your [ __ ]
body idiot you think you make new blood
that's why you get light-headed
sometimes you think you make new blood
you do make new blood you make new blood
while you're working out and none leaves
you make blood all the time yeah i think
he's right about that when you don't
you're not a woman
a [ __ ] lady
bleed it out six days a month
okay or five who knows i'm in it yeah
give me a heavy flow so my girl be
surprised about her period every month
i'm like yo [ __ ] write it down
every month
every month she got a [ __ ] attitude
for three days and they go
i got my period i had no clue i didn't
know my period was coming i had no clue
every 28 days
okay
how do you all not know this already is
she super regular say again is she super
regular
the same within two days every single
month you gotta tell her one time just
like yo my ball looks like a map dude
it's gonna be coming all the time yeah
it's gonna be coming all the time
[Laughter]
for real girls that's no excuse it's not
being surprised by your [ __ ] period
alright yeah so according to this
article this is spongy tissue and then
these are all the different conditions
were you still talking about dick brown
yeah yeah
damn moving on i'm trying to diagnose
that
diagnosis
come on let's talk about sucking dicks
or something bro
what's the next stop which one of these
conditions do you have you got ball
issues not dick issues what are those
akash's relatives
yeah that's
[Applause]